(music)
- Good morning again, and welcome.
I am Cynthia Roman,
Curator of Prints, Drawings, and Paintings
at The Lewis Walpole Library.
for those of you who don't me.
But I think I actually
know everybody out there.
Thank you for being here this morning.
I hope more people are
going to join us later,
recovering maybe from the
wonderful performance last night.
These two days of "The
Mysterious Mother" programs,
have been part of a series of celebrations
sponsored by The Lewis Walpole Library.
In this instance, partnering with
The Yale Center for British Art,
to celebrate the tercentenary
of Horace Walpole's birth,
which was actually last September 24th.
I hope I got that right.
I'm horrible with dates.
Stephen, is it the 24th?
This is the last of
the series of programs,
that Jonathan Kramnick,
the Maynard Mack professor of English,
and Director of The Lewis Walpole Library,
has conceived as the Walpalooza year,
and it was, it commenced appropriately,
and off that Strawberry Hill,
with the Walpole Wallow last fall.
Events also included a mini conference
on the Castle of Toronto,
that Jonathon organized at
The Lewis Walpole Library,
and later in the fall, George Haggerty,
distinguished professor of
English at UC Riverside,
delivered a lecture on the many lives
of Horace Walpole,
and led a workshop and
a round table on biography
and queering archives.
And we did an exhibition
and a two day conference
on "Global Encounters
and the Archives:
Britain's Global Empire in
the Age of Horace Walpole"
which was organized with Steve Pincus
and some Yale graduate students.
I just want to say a particular
thank you to Jonathan,
for his strong support of the staging
of "The Mysterious Mother."
The idea has been growing
for a really long time.
Years actually,
and it's been embraced
with lots of enthusiasm
from so many at The Lewis Walpole Library.
Fellows who have
contributed so essentially
their ideas and energies to
realizing these programs,
and I've had conversations with everyone
who has participated,
and just to say, it's
really wonderful for me,
to be part of this community of scholars
and Walpole enthusiasts,
every single one of whom,
from the very earliest notion,
responded with an unhesitating
and resounding yes,
I absolutely want to be part of that.
So thank you all for that.
I think actually, looking out there,
everyone was part of the audience.
for the fantastic performance or staged reading
of "The Mysterious Mother" last night,
and again, thank you to Misty,
for bringing that all
together, and our performers.
I hope that you were all
as entertained and captivated as I was.
But any of your friends and
colleagues who have missed it,
it was recorded.
It is being recorded today,
so make sure everyone knows.
It will be posted,
and Sue will make sure the word is spread.
We think that this was the
first North American performance for sure,
and one of the rare public
performances generally,
and we're going to hear more about that
from our distinguished panel later.
Today's mini conference,
is jointly organized by Jill Campbell.
Professor of English at Yale,
and a favorite faculty partner,
for The Lewis Walpole Library.
Jill, by way of a little anecdote,
included "The Mysterious Mother"
in her orals reading list,
when she was examined by Ron Paulson.
She's been a long-time fan I guess,
of "The Mysterious Mother,"
and published an essay,
"I am No Giant, Horace Walpole
and Heterosexual Incest,
and Love Among Men" in 1998,
which still continues to be cited.
Before I turn over to Jill,
whose going to chair the first panel,
I just want to acknowledge those
who have contributed so much.
Starting with Horace Walpole
himself and his wonders
and his prolific and diverse legacy,
and of course, W. S. Lewis,
and his wife Annie Burr Auchincloss Lewis,
whose life work, whose
vision for a study center
for the 18th century in Farmington,
and their bequest to Yale,
has ensured Walpole's legacy,
and allowed us to host
wonderful events like this.
and a serious fellowship program.
Also to the staff at the
Yale Center for British Art.
In particular, Jane Nowosadko,
whose been so wonderful helping
us organize and plan this.
To Beth Miller, Deputy
Director for Advancement,
who has supported us,
and of course to Amy Meyers,
who always warmly welcomes,
these kinds of programs,
and generously supports
The Lewis Walpole Library.
To the A.V. staff up there in the booth.
Thank you so much.
To Yale Broadcast Services.
And of course we all know
that none of this is possible,
without the extraordinary
work and dedication
of the staff at The Lewis Walpole Library,
who most of you know,
because you've been there.
In particular, Sue Walker
Head of Public Services,
and Michelle Privée, Senior
Administrative Assistant,
and also of course thank
you to Nicole Bouchée,
our Executive Director.
Thank you again for joining us today
to explore the many facets
of reading and staging Walpole's play.
I won't comment too much myself,
except to say that I personally
find "The Mysterious Mother"
a particularly compelling story,
full of deep anxiety, personal,
social, political, even religious,
And I don't know,
maybe that's more about me.
But I look forward to today's exploration
into the complexities of Walpole's vision
and its reception among
our speakers today.
Jill.
(audience applause)
- Good morning and welcome.
I want to second Cindy's
thanks to all the people,
dead and living,
that made our coming together
possible this morning.
Thank you all for coming
back this morning,
after last night's very exciting,
creative, gripping, funny,
over-the-top and yet powerful
and thought-provoking performance.
We're very fortunate today,
to have a rich array of scholars,
who can address for us a number of facets
of the questions raised by this
strange and remarkable play.
This morning's session is about reading
"The Mysterious Mother."
We're going to be
attending to its history,
as a written text,
and some of the interpretive questions
the full text raises.
As you know last night's performance
was brilliantly adapted and abridged
by David Worrall so it would be playable,
and that really worked.
It was so interesting to hear him talk
in the talk back after
the performance yesterday,
about the through line of
melodrama that he found
and so much that needed to fall away
in making it the kind of playable drama
that we enjoyed and experienced.
The speakers, this morning
and this afternoon,
are going to be addressing the full text
of The Mysterious Mother,
which is at least twice as long,
as what we heard last night.
Maybe more than twice as long.
They're going to be talking about passages,
and the ways the play entertains
a variety of kinds of
questions and problems
that may not have been fully evident
in the gripping drama you saw last night.
Just a word about format.
I'm going to be introducing
each speaker individually.
Popping back and forth.
They'll be presenting their
five relatively short papers,
and then we have, Cindy
and I have planned,
lots of time for the speakers
then to come together,
to sit at the front,
and have a Q and A among themselves,
but also with all of you.
We really hope for an
extended period of discussion.
And before I introduce Dale,
I want to take this moment
to shine a spotlight
on Cindy sitting there,
because this has been,
just a wonderfully deeply gratifying
and fun collaboration for all the people
who've been involved,
but Cindy is the one
who made it all happen,
who kept making sure that
all the connections were made
and that people's creative
and scholarly energies,
could be brought into this.
We are indebted to Cindy.
Our first speaker this
morning, Dale Townshend,
appeared making I'm sure
a deep impression on you,
as Peter the Porter.
Last night, wearing a
wonderful feather cap,
and high leather boots,
playing his important role,
in that catastrophic drama.
In his ordinary life,
he is Professor of Gothic Literature
in the Center for Gothic Studies,
at Manchester Metropolitan
University in the U.K.
He has published widely on Gothic writing
of the late 18th and early 19th centuries,
and has recently completed two studies
of the relationship
between gothic architecture
and gothic literature,
in the period: "Writing Britain's Ruins"
coedited with Michael
Carter and Peter Linfield,
and "Gothic Antiquity, History, Romance,
and Architectural Imagination, 1716-1840,"
which is forthcoming next year.
You can see this, with that
interest in gothic Architecture
and gothic literature, this is a scholar,
that Horace Walpole demands and needs,
and he will be speaking to us
on "Tthe mystery of 'The Mysterious Mother:'
Textual Lives and After Lives."
- Thank you very much Jill,
and thank you to everyone for coming,
but a special thanks
to Nicole and to Cindy
and to Michelle and Sue and
Jill and Jonathan and Jane.
Sounds a bit like a
poem I'm about to read.
But thank you to everyone.
It's a great pleasure to be here.
March the 15th, 1768.
"I finished a tragedy called
'The Mysterious Mother,'
which I'd begun December the 25th, 1768,
but I'd later decide for several months
while I went to Paris,
and while I was writing my 'Historic Doubts
on the reign of Richard III'
the last two acts were not now
as much finished as I intended."
Thus wrote Horace Walpole,
in "Short Notes of the
Life of Horatio Walpole,"
a draft autobiographical account
of his life, his letters,
and his most formative
experiences to date,
that he drew up in 1779.
Now it's often forgotten,
that "The Mysterious Mother"
was not Walpole's first foray into drama
and nor would it prove to be his last.
As early as June 1743,
he published in the journal "Old England,"
"The Dear Witches,"
a short dramatic reworking of "MacBeth,"
that figured his father Sir Robert Walpole
as the Duncan-like victim to a cabal
of political assassinators,
and later in 1773, he
wrote a short comedy.
"Nature Will Prevail,"
which was performed at the little theater,
in the Hay Market in June 1775,
and he published this together
with two very interesting essays,
entitled "Thoughts on Tragedy"
and "Thoughts on Comedy,"
in volume two of his
posthumous works in 1798.
We remember the "Thoughts on Tragedy"
had initially been formulated in letters
to the dramatist Robert Jephson in 1775.
The same playwright
who would later produce
a dramatic hybrid of both
"The Castle of Otranto"
and "The Mysterious Mother"
in "The Count of Narbonne" in 1781.
Completed by the middle of March 1768,
"The Mysterious Mother" was immediately
dispatched in manuscript form,
to some of Walpole's closest friends,
and within a month,
it had gratifyingly received
the approbation of his oracle of taste.
Of course John Chute,
who is not easily pleased,
and Thomas Gray who is
still more difficult.
"As you would not bear the
subject," he continued,
in a letter to George Montague,
in April of that year,
"I will say no more of it,"
before somewhat curiously claiming,
"that I'm not yet
intoxicated enough with it,
to think it would do for the stage,
though I wish to see it acted."
Walpole's expression here of ambivalent,
if not altogether paradoxical sentiments,
that his desire to see the play acted,
without it being performed on stage,
is central, I would argue,
to "The Mysterious Mother,"
and sentiments that are further evidenced
in his making of really
quite specific plans
for the involvement of his friends,
in the reading, performance,
and visual representation of the play.
Among them of course, Katherine Clive.
Hannah Pritchard. William
Mason, and Diana Beauclerk,
even as he continuously
decries its horrid,
disgusting, and ultimately
unperformable subject matter.
So, upon learning the year
after its completion,
that friends of Montagu,
had eagerly consumed the copy of the play
that Walpole had sent him.
Walpole, citing a line
from "Henry the IV." part I,
wrote that "I beg you would
keep it under lock and key;
it is not at all food for the public--
at least not till I am food for worms,
good Percy."
Now, I think this thus begins a complex process
of disclosure and obfuscation,
publication and suppression,
the assertion and the concealment
of authority and identity,
that characterizes the textual life
of the play from the moments
of its completion onwards.
Between the 14th of June,
and the 6th of August
of that year, 1768,
Walpole prints 50 copies of
the script at Strawberry Hill.
This in itself I think is a
significant publishing choice.
Unlike "Otranto," which in order to maintain
the antiquarian conceit
of the discovered document
had been published by
Thomas Lanz in London,
some three and a half years before.
"The Mysterious Mother"
was literary property
that required tight
regulation and control.
Printed versions, consequently,
were distributed to only a select few
of Walpole's most trusted friends,
among them Thomas Barret, Richard
Bull and Diana Beauclerk.
Now Walpole's manuscript annotations
in the copy that he sends to Bull,
indicate the extent to which
he policed the circulation
of the printed text.
This I what he writes.
"Mr. Walpole has sent Mr. Bull
the only copy he has left on the play,
but begs to have it returned,
as soon as he has read it,
and that he will not let it
go out of his hands."
But later in June 1779,
when Walpole eventually allows
Horace Mann to see a copy of the play
that he had long discussed
in letters to him,
he similarly asked that
it be returned to him
via post all the way from Florence.
Walpole's reluctance to
part with printed scripts,
encouraged people to
make of it manuscript copies
and at least seven of these
manuscript, fair copies
are held at The Lewis
Walpole Library today.
However, so as to
forestall the publication
of a spurious and unauthorized
edition of the play,
the upsetting news of
which he had received
from the actor John Henderson,
Walpole reluctantly gave his consent
to J. Dodsley in London to publish
"The Mysterious Mother" in 1781.
As he wrote in a suitably
gothic idiom to Cole,
"my tragedy has wandered into the hands
of some banditti booksellers,
and I am forced to publish it myself
to prevent piracy.
All I can do is condemn it
myself, and that I shall."
Unlike the first Strawberry
Hill edition of 1768,
this second edition bore no mention
of Walpole on its title page,
but included instead a one
and a half page preface,
that stressed the undisclosed author's
partly sincere, partly
faux modest reluctance
to bring it to public view.
You can see this on the slide.
"All the favor the author solicits
or expects," he writes,
"is to be believed how unwillingly
he has submitted to its appearance.
He cannot be more blamed,
than he blames himself
for having undertaken,
so disagreeable a story,
for having hazarded the publicity,
by letting it get out of his own hands."
There's a lot of talk about
hands, around this play.
Happily the mere advertising,
of this forthcoming authorized edition,
was enough to forestall
the intended piracy.
What happens is that the 1781 text,
though it's printed,
never actually proceeds to publication,
and Walpole is now content,
to give copies of this 1781 edition
to some of his friends,
in lieu of the first edition of 1768.
Having read this 1781 edition,
and urging its immediate
theatrical production,
David Erskine Baker in 1782,
writes that "knowing its merit,
we cannot but express our surprise,
that its author should wish to
withhold it from the public."
But I think by 1785,
Walpole is very clearly aware
of the fact that the play had become
somewhat of a collector's
object, or a rarity.
In fact, I'd go so far as to say,
he actively courted the sense of intrigue
that this entailed.
But the text publication
history does not end here.
November 1781, extracts of the play,
that had purportedly been
leaked from a manuscript copy,
were published in the
"St. James's Chronicle."
Now the newspapers, reprinting of Act I,
scene one and five,
was preceded by lines
that demonstrate that
"The Mysterious Mother"
had come to be regarded
as highly desirable literary property,
made all the more so by
the mystery, the secrecy,
the exclusivity, that
surrounded its circulation.
This is what the reprinting
of those two scenes
from Act I is preceded by.
"An anonymous correspondent
who highly favored
the "St. James's Chronicle,"
by the following desirable specimen
of an unpublished performance
which in the dramatic world,
we are truly sensible,
is held as a first rate curiosity."
I'm interested in that word curiosity,
as a kind of antiquarian object.
But the same paper followed
up this piracy one week later.
This time publishing Act III.
Scenes one and three, and Act IV scene IV,
in the regular poet's corner column.
Prefacing the extracts
with a similar affirmation
of the play's status as a rare
yet highly desirable artifact.
To the printer of the
"St. James's Chronicle,"
your readiness to oblige,
induces me to transcribe
for your poet's corner
another speech or two from
an invaluable manuscript.
Whilst it remains in my possession."
Further extracts are printed
in the "Public Advertiser" in November 1781.
Again in 1783,
but it's this latter 1783 leakage
of aspects of the text,
that prompts Walpole to
write to the publisher,
Henry Samson Woodfall,
in request of its immediate suppression,
even offering him financial compensation
for any imaginary benefit he says,
that he might receive from the impression.
At this time writes Walpole,
"the public must be curious to see,
more interesting articles,
than scenes of an old tragedy
on a disgusting subject,
a play which the author
thinks so little worthy
of being published that after
the first small impression
he is endeavored to suppress it,
as much as lies in his power."
1790, Walpole learned
through Joseph Cooper Walker
of another pirated edition of the text,
but this time in Dublin.
In the meantime, without
Walpole's knowledge,
Lord Charlemont suppressed
this publication
on the aged author's behalf,
and while Walpole remained
enormously grateful
towards his protector,
he had become by this time,
quite exhausted by the entire debacle.
"I have lived too long,
not to have divested myself.
both of vanity, and affected modesty."
Very interesting phrase.
Affected modesty.
He writes to Charlemont in February 1971.
"I have not existed to past seventy-three
without having discovered the futility
and triflingness of my own talents--
and at the same time it
would be impertinent,"
[Quick change of rhetorical direction]
"to pretend to think that there is no merit
in the execution of a tragedy,
on which I'd been so much flattered;
though I am sincere in condemning
the egregious absurdity
of selecting a subject
so improper for the stage
and even offensive to private readers--"
Dot, dot, dot.
"I will beg your lordship, if you please,
to signify to the bookseller,
that you withdraw your prohibition."
Albeit with Walpole's very
begrudgingly granted consent,
"The Mysterious Mother" was
duly published in Dublin,
by Archer, Jones, and White, in 1791.
Walpole's name only
mentioned in a cited extract
from a description of the play
that had first been published
in Biographica Dramatica in 1782.
Now a poem which I believe
has been reprinted on the
back of your program for today,
by one Florizel
that was published in "The World,"
Wednesday the 12th of October, 1791,
indicates something of
the public approbation
with which the eventual publication
of this mysterious piece was met.
Walpole, for this anonymous poet at least,
had restored the spirits of gothic genius
that had last been seen
on the English stage
in Shakespeare's plays.
There's a reprint of the Dublin edition
that is published in London in 1791,
which this time features Walpole's name
on the title page,
and another edition follows in 1796.
Now after so many years of resistance,
Walpole consents to the publication
of The Mysterious Mother
in the first volume of
his posthumous works.
That Berry oversees,
including in volume four,
a hitherto unpublished prologue,
that had been written in 1768.
Now of course if publication is a matter
of such urgency and anxiety,
performance is inconceivable.
Although as I've suggested,
there is evidence to suggest
that Walpole did seriously
contemplate its production.
An appreciative man summed up the views
of Walpole and his milieu,
when he wrote that "the subject may be
too horrid for the stage,
but the judicious management of it,
by preparing the reader
for the catastrophe.
The sublime ideas and expressions
so admirably adapted to the personages
make it a delicious
entertainment for the closet."
In Walpole's lifetime, as we know,
it remains a closet drama.
The likes of Goethe's "Faust,"
or later dramas of Byron and Shelley
and as such is intended only to be read
by a solitary reader,
or sometimes aloud in a small group
variously with or without
the author's knowledge or consent.
What is intriguing is the many accounts
of these reading experiences that remain.
My favorite is by the Scottish
antiquarian John Pinkerton
who recalls in "Walpoliana" of 1799,
a chilling nighttime
reading of Walpole's tragedy
at Strawberry Hill on the
20th of September 1784.
The occasion on which
Walpole leaves him alone,
we believe with the script at 11 PM
while he calls upon a neighbor.
Now as Walpole and Pinkerton both know,
the date of this reading, 20th September,
is in itself highly significant,
because it uncannily marks,
the anniversary of that
night so many years before,
on which the Count of Narbonne
was gored to death by the wild stag.
The night on which the Countess seduced
but then banished her son Edmund
and also the night on which Edmund returns
to Narbonne exactly 16 years later.
I think another uncanny coincidence,
that was Walpole's decision,
to call upon Catherine or Kitty Clive
on this night, the 20th of September 1784,
of all nights. As we know.
it was the Clive,
the famed comic actress who was
to speak the epilogue to the play.
Another decision that betrays I think
Walpole's intentions to see it performed.
From 1753, the Clive had been living
at Twickenham at Little Marble Hill.
A property owned by Walpole himself,
and upon her retirement
from the stage in 1769,
she moved to Little Strawberry Hill,
later known as Cliveden,
another Twickenham property
within the vicinity of Strawberry Hill
that Walpole had built in 1768,
and which he generously gifted to her.
So, 20th September 1784,
Pinkerton reads Walpole's
play at Strawberry Hill
thus marking the kind of random congruence
of a number of factors
that were intimately related
to Walpole's tragedy.
"This odd circumstance," writes Pinkerton,
conspired with the complete solitude
of the Gothic apartments,
to lend an additional impression
to the superstitious
parts of that tragedy.
In point of language,
and the true expression
of passion and feeling,
the new and just delineation
of monastic fraud,
tyranny and cruelty; it
deserves the greatest praise."
Now of course another well-known record
of a reader's engagement with the play
comes from the court journals
of Frances Burney, in 1786,
in which Burney recounts her shocked
even traumatized reactions,
to a group reading of the
play at Windsor Castle
merely four months after
her arrival at court.
Just to pick out a few lines.
"For myself, I felt a sort
of indignant aversion
rise fast and warm in my mind,
against the willful author
of a story so horrible:
all the entertainment and pleasure
I had received from Mr. Walpole
seemed extinguished by his lecture,
which almost made me regard him
as the patron of the vices
he had been pleased to record."
I think what happens is that
through these and other
such whispered accounts,
the withheld play achieved something
of a mythological status.
In all his reluctance to share it,
Walpole, the best
selling author of "Otranto"
has clearly made a mystery
of "The Mysterious Mother."
And thus we might begin
to track the afterlife,
of the play in romantic era Britain.
In 1792, in the preface
to her play "The Massacre,"
the radical writer Elizabeth Inchbald
claimed that her own decision
to write and publish the play
yet withhold it from production,
was directly informed by the precedent
that Walpole had set in
"The Mysterious Mother."
But to conclude the
influence of Walpole's play,
goes well beyond the
late 18th century stage.
As a primarily textual
phenomenon in its day,
its natural destination, I think,
were the prose genres
of romantic era fiction.
I think the play opens up
imaginative possibilities
that later gothic fiction
would come to exploit.
For it was in a drama with art which
such later gothic representations
of brother sister incest,
in say Mathew Lewis's "The Monk" of 1796,
would not have been possible,
Ann Radcliffe twice used
extracts from the play
as epigraphs to The Italian of 1797.
Reworking the relationship
between the Countess and Father Benedict,
in that between the Marchesa di Vivaldi
and the notorious villain Father Schedoni.
Later romantics were
equally enamored of it.
In the preface to Marino Faliero,
Byron praised it as "a
tragedy of the highest order,
and not a puling love play."
Walpole, he continued,
"is the father of the
first romance [Otranto],
and of the last tragedy in our language,
and surely worthy of a higher place
than any other living writer,
be he who he may."
Walter Scott was altogether
less enthusiastic,
when he anthologized the play,
in Ballantyne's "Modern
British Drama," in 1811.
Later, in "Lives of the Novelists,"
Scott would pass the play
as "a horribly impressive
but disgusting drama."
Irrespective of whether
it was revered or reviled,
one might sincerely
ponder the extent to which
some of the greatest
sexually transgressive texts
of canonical romanticism,
and here I'm thinking of Shelley's,
"Cenci" or "Laon and Cythna,"
or Mary Shelley's "Mathilda,"
and especially double incest plot
of John Polidori's "Ernestus Berchtold,"
possibly even Byron's "Manfred,"
would have been possible,
without "The Mysterious Mother."
and that cultivated sense of secrecy,
and mystery that surrounded it.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
- Thank you so much Dale.
Our next speaker is Matthew M. Reeve.
He is Associate Professor of Art History
and Queen's National Scholar,
at Queen's University,
and a fellow of The
Society of Antiquaries.
Working in both the
medieval and modern periods,
he has just completed
a revisionist account
of gothic architecture, sexuality,
and aesthetics in the
circle of Horace Walpole.
It will be coming out in 2019,
and it follows from essays
in "The Art Bulletin,"
"Architectural History,"
"The Burlington Magazine," and other venues.
Matthew will be speaking to us
on "'The Mysterious Mother'
and crypto-Catholicism
in the Circle of Horace Walpole."
- Anyway, thank you very
much for having me here
and to our wonderful support,
and I wanna also thank
really really quickly
The Lewis Walpole Library,
because they gave me my
start on this project
in a wonderful way over
a summer fellowship,
and they also taught me how
to play professional croquet.
Which was an amazing thing.
Those of you who've been there,
know exactly what I'm talking about.
As you heard this is a special treat
for me to be here,
because I'm not officially
an English specialist.
Nor an 18th century-ist, in fact,
but an art historian and a medievalist.
My interest in Walpole
and his homoerotic circle
of male friends and designers and patrons,
concern their pivotal role in the shaping
of the gothic idiom in the 18th century,
and their art writing,
their art and architectural
patronage particularly,
and in my case, tangentially
their literature.
Although it's seldom understood as such,
Walpolian gothic as an historical idiom
confronted and was informed by
its historical roots in
medieval Catholicism.
In England the official
end of Catholicism,
with the 16th century
dissolution of the monasteries
established a fundamental
break in religious structures,
and by many accounts,
including that of Horace Walpole,
its heritage in gothic architecture.
Walpole's gothic reflects a
complex response to Catholicism
that was variously critical and porodic,
romantic and even erotic,
but like many goths and antiquaries
before and after him,
it is motivated fundamentally,
if not straight forwardly,
by mourning for a lost
spiritual and aesthetic past.
In setting this up I want to say
a little bit first of all about
Walpole's appraisal of Catholicism,
and then ask how this context might inform
a reading of "The Mysterious Mother."
It goes without saying,
that few men within Walpole's circle,
were either Catholic,
or Catholic converts.
They could be more usefully
understood as crypto-Catholics.
Walpole described himself
as a Protestant goth
and a strain of anti-Catholicism
runs through his writing
as of course, it does
for the period itself.
Yet he felt no tension,
in writing to Reverend William Cole,
saying things like I like
potpourri as well as you do
and I've shown that I do.
I like it like I like
chivalry and romance.
They all furnish one
with ideas and visions,
which Presbyterianism does not.
A gothic church or convent,
fills one with romantic dreams.
Walpole playfully
allegorized Strawberry hill
as a Catholic Shrine,
calling it a gothic
Vatican of Greece and Rome,
and he was clear that
aspect of its interiors
were intentional approximations
of the splendor and gaudiness
to use his word, of medieval Catholic art,
with all the glory of potpourri.
Walpole and his circle actively
and playfully explored the Catholic,
and quasi-religious nature,
in the houses that they built.
The Strawberry Hill oratory for example,
was a functionless exterior prayer niche,
enclosed within iron rails,
with basins for holy water,
and a 15th century Bronze angel.
Walpole's famous letter
in 1753 to Horace Mann,
describes his plans for his new monastery
at Strawberry Hill.
He says, "I am greatly
impatient for my alter,
and so far from mistrusting its goodness,
I only fear it will be too good
to expose to the weather,
as I intended to be a
recess in the garden.
I was going to tell you that my house
is so monastic,
that I have a little hall
decked with long lean saints
in lean arched windows,
and with long columns that
we call the Paraclete,
in memory of the Eloisa's Cloister."
This is typical of the range
of religious significations,
and frankly, in jokes
that he and his circle shared,
in which Catholicism, its rites,
settings, and rituals,
were subject to the highly nuanced
coterie taste and understanding.
He concludes with a reference
to the Paraclete or the entrance hall
as I show it to you here.
The name of which is borrowed from Pope's
"Eloisa and Abelard" of 1717, of course.
Elsewhere in describing Dicky Bateman.
His kind of frenemy,
we might say these days,
at his building of his villa
by the Strawberry Hill designers.
Walpole claims, and I quote that
"Bateman's villa had changed its religion.
I converted it.
--I converted it from Chinese to Gothic,
and that his monkish chambers,
were always dressed as
though in full mourning."
Unquote.
These men would develop
a rich series of tropes
to describe themselves as brother monks,
abbots, and their houses as nunneries,
monasteries and so forth.
They would also perform
their crypto-Catholism,
through faux liturgies
at the vine in Hampshire,
with ancient mass books and incense.
Where they had what they
called, quote, unquote,
a most Catholic enjoyment
of the chapel there.
A quotation I'm still
trying to understand.
Walpole could allegorize a
visit to Strawberry Hill
by George Montagu as the
festival of St. George
and speak of the gorgeous saints
and stained glass he acquired,
and so forth and so on and so on.
Catholicism and the gothic shared
a common temporal location,
in Walpole's historiography.
This is an important point.
i.e. variously, up to and even after 1540,
particularly with reference
for literature in Shakespeare
as we heard yesterday.
For Walpole, both were associated
with a form of sensory, ethical,
and labidonal freedom,
what he called visionary enjoyment.
A state of being he felt was diminished,
by the extinction of Catholicism,
chivalry, of the gothic style itself.
With the dissolution of the monasteries.
As an historical moment
of rupture and change,
he considers the dissolution
in Protestantism itself
to reflect a reform of human emotional
and intellectual aesthesis.
Reform, in other words,
was not a good thing,
for Horace Walpole.
In architecture, the classicism
that followed the
dissolution was replaced.
Pardon me.
Dissolution replaced the gothic
in Walpole's developmental theory.
In other words, the English Renaissance.
and this was understood by him
as a destructive reform
of the built environment.
It was the result of stifled
human aesthetic agency.
Of creativity being hemmed in
by the oppressive rules of classicism,
or reform or Protestantism,
as his argument follows.
The gothic becomes a style and a period,
of unrestrained creativity.
A space for the free unfiltered,
and unregulated projection
of the imagination.
As such, a revival of the gothic,
meant not simply return to the forms
of later medieval architecture,
but also to its spiritual
and performative modes,
or at least particularly specific
and camp even conception of them,
and of course in this he has his critics.
Madame du Deffand would respond to
"The Mysterious Mother," by stating,
I do not like Abelard and Eloise at all.
Something in this case,
she connects to the play.
Whether ancient or modern,
her endearments, her passions,
are not my style.
Walpole responds noting that the play
is presented as a kind of gothic,
which would not be found in your,
in other words French theater.
A kind of polite dropping of the mic
if there ever was one.
As a subversive other mode
of spiritual and political regions
within parts of England,
Catholicism and non normative sexuality
were marked by a history of
tropological substitution
and inter implication for
contemporary audiences.
Offering the fantasy
of monosexual culture.
Many of the gothicisms
in Walpole's circle,
suggest queer appropriations
of Catholic rituals and aesthetics.
Beneath the cowl of monastacism
was a cult of male homo erotic community.
Indeed the cloister had
been usefully understood
as a preparatory space,
for the closet in modern constructions
of homosexuality in recent research.
So much is clear,
but to nuance this point.
It does need a lot of nuance,
monasticism was also used as a guise
to perform overtly heterosexual license
as in the case of sir Francis Dashwood
and the Medmenham Monks,
just up the Thames from Strawberry Hill,
who performed an orgiastic
exploits with nuns.
Quote, unquote, nuns,
within gothic settings.
The so-called Hellfire caves,
and we can of course trace
such an association between Catholicism
and alternate or unreformed sexuality,
across many cultural
productions contemporaneously.
Including this newly acquired print here,
at The Lewis Walpole Library.
Thanks to Cindy for sending this.
I just got this a week ago.
Walpole's use of gothic,
to describe "The Mysterious Mother"
and his own crypto-Catholic
practices aside,
such as they may be,
what does this have to do with the play?
Well, superficially at least,
the continental gothic past,
or Catholic past, excuse me,
becomes a space that normalizes,
or at least makes possible
radical sexual difference.
It facilitates the
story's central narrative
of incest as a Freudian family romance,
safely removed from a
contemporary English context,
and here I'm recalling George Haggerty's
remarkable observation,
that the monastery
functions as a precursor
to the laboratory in Georgian culture.
As a space to explore and
examine sexual difference.
The play's overt focus on Catholicism,
its rights, its apparently
villainous cleric associations,
has stood at the center
of the play's reception
from Paul Baines's view of Horace Walpole,
what he calls "a manifestly anti-sacredotal focus."
Excuse me.
To a 1797 critique which
stated that, and I quote,
Mr. Walpole was a bitter foe to priests,
without distinction,
and seems to have had no great reverence
for sacred mysteries,
or the doctrinal parts,
of the Christian system.
But I want to follow Walpole here himself,
in his famous postscript,
in which he says, I quote,
"the villainy of Benedict was planned
to divide the indignation of the audience,
and to intercept some
of it from the Countess.
Nor will the blackness of this
character appear extravagant
if we call to mind the crimes
committed by Catholic Churchman,
when the reformation, not
only provoked their rage,
but threatened them with total ruin."
While the play clearly exploits
the writing cliches of villanous
or licentious Catholic clergy,
Walpole goes somewhere to historicize,
and even justify Benedict's actions.
In this passage the Monks really are
the victims of a changing tide.
In one sense the play turns,
on the thwarting eventual demise
of Catholicism's very structures.
In this sense Narbonne is
like T.S. Elliot's "Wasteland,"
suffering a period of
moral and physical decline
after the transgression
of 16 years previous.
The Countess has largely neglected
her traditional role as
a benefactor to the abby
and as a result it is partially ruinous.
But more importantly
as Benedict understands it,
she has neglected her spiritual role
to her priest and confessor.
Benedict continually reaches out to her,
but she shuns and mocks him,
knowing the church could never
correct or contain her sin.
Here the often cited parallel
between the medieval confessional
as a precursor to the modern
psychiatrist sofa seems apt.
Since religion grandly declines,
and is even replaced,
with the rise of psychoanalysis,
to follow one narrative anyway.
Having for all intents and purposes,
fired her psychiatrist,
in the sense the Countess has disrupted
the traditional
epistemological relationship
between the family and their faith.
Thus upsetting the structures of knowledge
and power medieval Catholicism.
As a result it is the castle,
and not the monastery
that becomes the physical container
and site for the exploration of trauma,
unmediated by Catholic confession.
This might help us to understand
why Walpole locates the plot,
in a liminal space of the reformation.
Rather than the period of the crusades,
as in Otranto.
The reformation, not only historicizes
the actions of the captain clergy,
but it thematizes them as well.
And so too does it position
the Countess's very subjectivity,
between an exterior piety,
constant with Catholic confession,
and an interior redemptive piety,
consistent with Protestantism,
and as Dale and I discussed last night,
perhaps she was already at a process
of conversion herself.
If I'm hinting here at
a strain of apology,
or something like apology,
in Walpole's construction,
of the Catholic in gothic past,
I do so for a good reason.
Walpole and the medievalists
of his generation,
inherited an historiographical tradition
from the early modern
antiquarian predecessors.
People like John Stowe, and
William Dugdale and others,
that look to the dissolution
as a fundamental break,
in the religious and social
character of a country,
and yearned for a return,
to the predisolution of Catholic past.
Walpole absorbed these ideas,
and made them central to his home.
He even used various now lost monuments.
Illustrated in Dugdale's text,
to become the gothic
installations at Strawberry Hill,
thereby imprinting to
use Walpole's own word,
this nostalgic vision of the Catholic past
upon the inside of this famous home.
And I just gave you a second example here,
that's a little bit more
pleasant to look at.
Now Walpole's crypto-Catholicism,
was of course a tangled ambivalent aspect
of his historicism.
Of his very nostalgia.
He could for example,
offer a lament upon seeing
Kings College Chapel at Cambridge.
Again, after some years,
he says that penetrated me
with a visionary longing
to be a monk in it.
A pretty odd comment to be sure,
for a collegiate rather
than a monastic foundation.
But here as elsewhere in all of this,
I think we fail at Walpole
at taking him literally
and reducing his writings
to legalistic documents
that prove or not specific ideas,
rather than interrogating
them with his own language.
Now I want to close with a
passage from a wonderful book,
Michael Anne Holly's recent book,
"The Melancholy Art."
In which she describes the art historian's
own subjective position,
against her own historical subject.
A passage that I think,
might usefully gloss
Walpole's own historicism
vis-à-vis the Catholic past,
and she says nostalgia is simply
not capacious enough a word
to name the source of the sensation.
This homesickness of things.
What we momentarily encounter there,
is the living pulsating
afterlife of the past."
Thank you.
(audience applause)
- Thank you Matthew.
Our next speaker is Nicole Garret.
She's a part time faculty member at
SUNY Stonybrook and Adelphi University,
and a recent Lewis Walpole Library Fellow.
Nicole has co-edited two
novels of Frances Sheridan's.
Sidney Bidulph novels
that are available through Broadview.
and also coauthored several essays
on 19th century religious enthusiasm.
Dr. Garret's current research
is on literary and cultural narratives
of maternal grief and
discourses of consolation
in the long 18th century.
Her paper today is titled,
"Misreading in 'The Mysterious Mother'."
- Thank you.
I don't know what makes me more nervous.
This room or this microphone.
I want to thank of course,
The Lewis Walpole Library,
and Cindy Roman, and all of the support
that you've given me over
the past two years or so.
I will never forget and
never stop coming back,
as long as I'm invited.
"The Mysterious Mother" is a
funny play in several ways.
As Horace Walpole was fond of saying,
"the world is a comedy to those that think,
and a tragedy to those that feel,"
and his play does seem to be a reflection
of the world as he saw it.
It may be easy to miss the
comedic aspects of the play
especially in re-reading,
because there's so much to wonder at.
I'm sorry, there's so much to wonder at,
in the subject of the mother son incest.
The comedy, like the tragedy,
is a product of characters misreading,
both signs in nature,
and The Mysterious Mother herself.
In a letter to William Mason in 1769,
Walpole stated his aim was to, quote,
present a character whose penitence
was not degraded by superstitious bigotry.
Unquote.
Of course William Mason wanted him
to try to change the fact that,
change his character's deliberate
going to bed with her son,
and make it a little bit more palatable.
In that sense, Walpole needed to expose
and satirize bigotries and pieties
that generate comic or tragic misreadings,
so when the monks Martin and Benedict,
shudder at a funeral dirge,
thinking it's a voice beyond the grave,
saying forebear, we laugh,
but when others misread
the Countess as a mother
whose supposedly natural
maternal instincts
have become corrupted by meddling priests,
the effect can be tragic.
What I'd like to do in my short time,
is look at the function of
bigotry as an interpretive lens.
How it in effect shields the Countess,
from discovery of her sins,
and finally how the Beauclerk drawings
express Walpole's themes,
without testing the reader's tolerance
for mother son incest,
or what might be called
our bigotries and pieties.
In the beginning, "The Mysterious Mother"
is mysterious because she's improper.
She's a bad mother.
She defies expectations,
and she fails to provide for needs.
Nobody really knows the Countess.
We don't even learn her first name.
Usually she has no confidant,
or lady in waiting.
Her reputation is the product
of rumor and misreading.
Benedict is her would be confessor.
At first only knows her enough
to know he can't quite figure her out.
Her interpreters either read her
as a hardened heretic,
or having an over abundance
of feminine piety.
Furthermore they see her
relationship to her son
as symptomatic of some religious state.
Edmund's friend Florian for instance,
is certain that, quote, religious mummery,
and rank fanaticism,
is the cause of her
separation from her son
and he denies any sort
of moderation to women.
I never knew a woman but loved
our bodies or our souls too well.
That was one of the great
lines from last night.
He sees her as a quote, ruthless mother,
lacking affection for her son,
while giving away all
his riches to the church,
and when Peter the Porter speaks
of his lady's ever heaven directed eye,
he's giving support to the idea,
that maternal feeling was spent somehow
in religious devotion.
Florian's pieties about
motherhood as an affective state
do not allow him to see that the Countess
does not need to be
rescued from her monks.
The first scene between Florian and Peter,
raises the pressing question,
just how religious is she?
And just how is she religious?
The monk Martin, is another one,
attached to his dichotomies.
In contrast to Florian,
Martin reads the Countess's refusal
to take confession, believe
in prophetic visions,
or take solace in
incantations as rank heresy.
Benedict however realizes
that simple dichotomies.
Mother, monster, saint or heretic,
don't accurately explain her behavior.
She thinks too much.
Is too much a logician,
and these he says, are pagan virtues.
Although he is determined
to use it to bad ends,
Benedict recognizes that
religious difference
exists on a spectrum,
and the Countess confronts him,
with aspects of the pagan,
and the Christian.
The devotee, and the heretic,
as she reasons through her own perdition.
Because she's less mysterious to him,
she's more malleable.
He can manipulate her impulses,
and has seen glimmers of success
in that his prophecies
sometimes haunt her dreams.
Peter the Porter has seen her walk around,
quote with frantic
gesture in a hurried step.
The philosopher Countess it seems
has lapses for which she
duly chastises herself.
Subtending the dialogue between
the Countess in Benedict,
many of those scenes we
didn't get to see last night,
probably because they
would have put us to sleep,
are echoes of Hume's
"Natural History of Religion,"
in which he posits that
primitive humans progressed
from polytheism to monotheism,
as they turned to contemplating
the natural order,
rather than the relationship,
between aberrations in the natural world
and its relationship to life.
In other words, the
practice of interpreting
natural phenomena as
harbingers of events of life,
is a primitive impulse.
However, since neither polytheism,
nor monotheism are inherently rational,
humans may slip back into the
quote, superstitious bigotries
that we see very much on
display in Walpole's tragedy.
"The Mysterious Mother" is always in danger
of slipping back into superstition,
and into the momentary madness
that led her to bed her son.
Later in the play, when racked by grief,
she thinks she sees her husband
when she beholds her son.
She hears ghosts.
She believes herself dead.
She asks for spells to relieve her misery.
At other times, she scoffs
heroically at Benedict
and bests him with logic and biting wit.
In short, she wavers,
traveling the whole spectrum,
between skepticism and
frenzied enthusiasm.
Walpole succeeds in presenting a character
whose penitence is not degraded
by superstitious bigotry
in part by dramatizing her resistance.
She says, quote, only weak
minds want their soul's fortune
told by oracles and holy jugglers.
Unquote.
Her religious opinions are
ones she's reasoned into
because of affliction,
regarding her charity work.
She also says, quote, "I
did not feel for others.
I did not think to feel for others,
because I did not think."
By the end of Act I, it's established,
that the Countess's religious positions
and opinions on priestcraft
are far from what they're reputed to be,
and that her freedom from superstition,
depends on maintaining a
certain mental fortitude.
Her parental behavior,
operates on a similar parallel spectrum.
The Countess's relationship to her son,
is not, as the other characters believe,
dictated by her religious zealotry,
or relationship to priests,
who as she says quail before her.
Toni Bowers' term, effective motherhood,
and terms effective motherhood,
and economic motherhood,
are useful starting points
for understanding the
Countess's maternal behavior.
Effective motherhood
being unavailable to her.
That is the feeling, the nurturing,
the hugging and the kissing.
She acts our her parental role
rather as a steward of her
son's ancestral wealth.
Benedict reads this behavior as loveless.
He says, she loves him not.
Yet mistress of his fortunes.
She loves him not,
yet mistress of his fortunes.
His ample exhibition speaks her bounty.
She destines him whatever
her father's love
gave blindly to her will.
Edmund still believing
that he was banished
for an affair with Beatrice,
calls his mother rigid,
but denies she's squandering his money.
He says, to me her hand is as bounteous,
as her heart is cold.
Walpole's play therefore
takes up questions
of maternal difference that are present
in other mother fictions of the period.
Defoe's "Roxana" for instance,
also reasons that economic motherhood.
that is caring for the
material needs of the child,
is a meat substitute for
affection and nurturing.
Neither Roxana nor the Countess,
are able to tend to their children,
or love them in conventional ways,
and both find their religious
systems of their birth,
to be insufficient for
supporting their experiences,
or bearing them up under trial.
Where Roxana works out
biblical interpretations
that support her peculiar
brand of motherhood,
Walpole's Countess assumes
the role of the father.
The ruler of lands, money, and children,
as Benedict calls her,
Mistress of Fortunes.
Economic stewardship might feel unloving,
and Edmund certainly feels that it is,
but the Countess has earned his respect
through behaviors more immediately
associated with fathers.
Like a medieval or early
modern Chesterfield,
the Countess writes letters to her son,
teaching him how to be a man.
These letters seem to
countermand her reputation
as a preying Magdalene.
Edmund says, quote, her letters Florian,
such unstudied strains
of virtuous eloquence.
This praying Magdalene,
enjoins my courage to emulate
my great forefather's deeds.
Tell me that shame and
guilt alone are mortal,
and death but bars the possibility
of frailty and embalms on tainted honor.
Unquote.
In reaffirming his banishment,
she enjoins him to obey her commands,
and she speaks of her masculine soul.
She has overall little
respect for mothers.
Seeing them as dispensable, or worse.
Trust me she tells Florian,
a father's guardian arm,
were well worth all the
treasures it withheld.
A mother might be spared.
Indeed.
For the Countess motherhood is corruptible
and has brought her misery,
but fatherhood seems possible,
straightforward, indispensable even,
and yet the mother cannot be spared.
Both Edmund and Adeliza,
long for maternal affection.
For her part although she cannot
lavish Edmund with affection,
the Countess is overcome with
protective emotion at the sight of him.
Desperate to shield him and Adeliza
from the knowledge of her sins.
Overcome with guilt,
the pull toward effective
motherhood moves separately,
but in tandem with her backsliding
into superstition and madness.
Georgina Locke had a great line last night
that did come through in the play.
"Loved him.
oh nature, bleeding at my heart."
The nature is pulling at her.
Just by the words, loved him.
Being asked if she loves him.
The Countess resists certain
kinds of natural impulses
both to superstition and to affect,
only for as long as she
can remain mysterious.
As long as she seems something
unnatural or other worldly,
and the effect of her natural
passions remains hidden
and the effect of her natural passions
remains hidden and
insulated from manipulation.
Like those who experienced
the 1750 London earthquakes,
the absurdities of whom Walpole
wrote about shortly after,
the shock of terrible events,
separates her from her reason.
Reason is no match for an earthquake.
Shared themes of oscillation,
between reason and superstition,
light and dark, are what
Diana Beauclerk's drawings,
why they're such fitting illustrations
for Walpole's play.
In her drawings some of
what you've already seen
up on the screen,
human characters, natural elements
give them cover and protection,
while also simultaneously,
reaching out to draw
them into the darkness.
This darkness is a retreat and a cover,
but it also has an ominous and creeping,
and inescapable quality.
They sanitize the topic,
that Walpole admitted was disgusting.
He adored Beauclerk's drawings,
because he said they're expressive,
but quote, they do not
shock like the original.
Unquote.
The drawings have this ability
to express the interplay
between reason, nature,
penitence and superstition,
in a way that separates
them from the incest plot
that propels those themes in the play.
They're emblems of his ideas,
and in a way they're a guide
to reading "The Mysterious Mother" right.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
- Thank you so much Nicole.
Our next speaker is Cheryl Nixon.
She is an Associate Provost
at the University of
Massachusetts, Boston.
She also serves as an
Associate Professor of English
specializing in 18th century literature.
The rise of the novel
in law and literature.
She is the author of "The Orphan
in Eighteenth-century Law and Literature:
"Estate, Blood and Body,"
published by AshGate in 2011.
In addition to editing an anthology
of commentaries on the
novel, "Novel Definitions,"
she's published articles on topics,
such as guardianship
and legal recordkeeping,
and I was inspired by, this glimpse
into her activities as a scholar,
and teacher and citizen.
She comments.
Cheryl comments that her
favorite form of scholarship
has been creating public
rare book exhibitions
with her students for
the Boston Public Library
including the exhibit "Crooks, Rogues,
and Maids Less Than Virtuous."
"Books in the streets
of 18th century London,"
and her talk today is about,
not the Mysterious Mother,
but "The mysterious orphan" in this play.
- Great, thank you.
I think you can tell what the emphasis
on the idea of the
orphan in my scholarship,
but indeed I will emphasize
the idea of the orphan.
I guess my topic is not that mysterious.
In this mini paper, I'd like to turn us
to a reading of "The Mysterious Mother
that emphasizes the
perspective of the child.
I'd like to argue that the play
dramatizes the family's ability
to recreate the child,
and more specifically,
the parent's ability to redefine
the biological child as an orphan.
Obviously, I'm emphasizing
the Countess's positioning
of her child Adeliza as an orphan,
but I would also like to emphasize
her positioning of her
son Edmund as an exile.
a symbolic orphan barred
from his home and mother.
Resulting from this
redefinition of the family,
the play dramatizes the orphan's
feelings of loss and confusion.
Feelings of powerlessness.
Placelessness.
Selflessness.
Simply put, the mother's
purposeful transformation
of her child into an orphan
is an obvious act of familial betrayal,
and I would like us to see orphaning
as a shocking act of betrayal.
Although of course we focus on incest
as the play's most
horrible act of betrayal,
I'm going to argue that orphaning
is just as striking and shocking.
Let me convince you that orphaning
is one of Walpole's key
concerns in the play.
I'll emphasize three points.
That the orphan is a duplicated figure,
throughout the play.
Therefore it offers structure to the play.
That orphaning is a strategy
of familial reconfiguration
that furthers incest's
familial redefinition.
Orphaning is kind of on
the spectrum with incest,
and orphaning emphasizes the
activity of interpretation
and the idea of unequal
knowledge, unequal power,
in that act of interpretation.
Obviously there's a duplication
of orphan figures throughout the play.
So that we do not miss
the idea of the orphan.
I'll make the obvious point,
that the orphan is repeated
and becomes a way of
structuring character,
emphasizing the children's dependent
relationship on the Countess.
Although we are used to emphasizing
the Countess's emotions,
the play obviously emphasizes
the emotion of the children
Adeliza and Edmund.
The pain of homelessness.
The pain of not knowing one's parents.
Of being rejected, of being exiled.
With Adaliza, the orphan
ward overseen by the Countess
is obviously our key figure here,
and there's many many quotes I could read,
but I'm just going to pick a few key quotes
for each character.
Adaliza emphasizes the
mystery of family origins
that she represents,
and she's constantly questioning
who are my parents?
Where am I coming from?
Here's just one example of that,
that occurs early in the play.
The Countess says, "thou dearest
orphan to my bossom come,
and vent thy little sorrows,"
and Adeliza continues,
then ultimately says,
"when have I wept,
but when thou hast refused
to let that Adeliza call thee mother.
I know I was not worthy of such an honor.
Too splendid for a child of charity.
I know I am most unworthy."
And of course, we know that
Adeliza is verging on truth
by wanting to call her the mother,
but that kind of confusion and weeping
and saying I am not unworthy,
but I want to call you my mother.
That confusion of feelings,
is I think what Walpole's
emphasizing here.
I'll move on to Edmund as an exiled child.
I'd like to also argue that
he plays a bit of a
role of an orphan also.
My research is on the legal orphan,
and legally a child who
is inheriting an estate,
if the father dies,
they would have legally
been considered an orphan
unless the mother had
been specifically named
as the guardian of the child.
I think that probably would
have been the case in this story
because of the way, as
we were just hearing,
the Countess oversees
the estates of Edmund.
However, I think we want to emphasize that
it would have been very common
for a child that lost a father
to have been put in the category of orphan
in the 18th century.
When we first meet Edmund,
he emphasized this banishment,
this rejection by his mother.
He sort of is duly deparented.
This is of course the obvious
thing you saw last night,
where he describes stealing
into Beatrice's chamber
and that's where again we know
that it's verging on the
understanding of incest
that he's not quite seeing.
Quote, "How my mother
became apprised, I know not,
but her heart never too partial to me,
grew estranged.
Estranged, aversion in its fellest mood
scowled from her eye,
and drove me from her sight.
She called me impious.
Named my honest lewdness
a profanation of my father's ashes.
I knelt and wept." And it continues on
talking about bathing her hand with tears,
and how she snatches it away,
and how it's horrible.
Very overwraught emotions.
Later Florian asks,
why would you return?
Why do you return to this?
Why do you want to return home?
Edmund says I am weary Florian
of such a vagrant life.
We heard that line last night also.
That sense of feeling
estranged, rejected, weary.
Excessive emotion.
Edmund's constantly referring to that.
I'd like to emphasize as another example
of the repetition of orphans,
the chorus of orphans,
that we heard briefly last night
and sort of had a shadowy figure
of some figures up on the screen
representing the orphans.
Obviously here I think Walpole
is doing a very over the top duplication
of the idea of the orphan,
so we do not miss.
We do not miss the figure of the orphan.
They witness supernatural evidence
of the family's sin,
and they importantly do not understand it.
This would be a point that
I'll emphasize a little
bit later in the paper.
The Countess when she first
introduces the orphans
calls them my little orphans.
These are part of as a benefactress
who is benefiting from her charity.
The orphans sing a hymn.
I'll just read the last
two stanzas of the hymn,
but I want to emphasize here,
is that they are playing the role,
of facing or covering up
the family crime also.
The orphan's hymn goes,
hear us harmless orphans hear,
for who who dries our falling tear.
Hush her sorrows, calm her breast.
Give her what she gives us, rest.
Guard our spotless souls from sin.
Grant us virtues palm to win.
Clothe the penitent with grace,
and guilt's foul spots efface, efface."
Here obviously they're
positioning themselves
in relationship to the Countess.
They're not her children,
but in a way they are her children.
They're her little orphans,
that are trying to come up with
a way to calm her breast,
to hush her sorrows,
and obviously they end with that line.
They're trying to efface her guilt
and the foul spots on her.
The orphan becomes a cover or a mask
for the source of guilt.
We could continue to analyze
each of these characters in greater depth,
but what I want to emphasize
is that the orphan is a larger structure,
in structuring the obsessions of the play,
and orphaning is a strategy.
My second point is that orphaning
is a strategy of familial reconfiguration,
that furthers the incest theme.
Orphaning provides another example
of Walpole exploring the
limits of family bonds
and asking, what is the
breaking point of the family?
The Countess's activity,
of redefining the child as an orphan,
parallels or compounds
the crime of incest.
As we were just hearing,
I think we're very comfortable asking,
what's the source of the Countess's pain,
and emphasizing that
hidden idea of incest,
and I think that we also
want to emphasize this
questioning that is
coming from the children.
Why did she banish Edmund,
and who is Adeliza's parents?
This incest question leads
to these further questions
that involve the children.
Orphaning provides, not
just another example,
of her immoral manipulation of the family,
but provides an example
of her conscious decision
to extend that manipulation.
To give it structure and permanence
by making it an overt part of her family.
The Countess believes that orphaning
can hide her crime of incest.
Can in effect, provide a
solution to the incest.
However, we know this is twisted logic.
I think as good readers we know,
any solutions like this,
is only going to compound
and further that original crime
and not succeed in masking it.
What I would like us to consider,
is that the crime of purposeful orphaning
is in some ways even more horrific
than incest for two reasons.
First, because it's an
expression of excess.
Excessive desire, of course,
leads to the incest,
but also leads to, and is accompanied by,
this excessive rejection of the child.
In some ways, these two opposites
are yolked together through orphaning.
Excessive desire, and excessive rejection.
I want to emphasize
they're both excessive.
They're both very over the top,
because of this duplication of orphaning,
and secondly because it's not
just a singular occurrence
the orphaning becomes a daily occurrence.
It's a form of family
betrayal that's repeated
and what I want to emphasize is
it becomes routinized, normalized.
It's a planned form of excess.
Again, it's even in that group of orphans,
that she positions an
entire chorus of orphans
that is receiving her charity.
It becomes normalized,
and that's the horror,
is that it's become daily.
It's become routine.
It's planned excess.
As my third point,
I want to emphasize that orphaning,
is connected to the
activity of interpretation.
The orphan introduces the
unknown into the family.
Who are your parents?
Who are your siblings?
Where did you come from?
Where are you going?
The orphan is a mystery
that needs to be solved,
and these characters are
constantly questioning,
who am I because of their orphan status.
The orphan thus heightens
our interest in interpreting
the family as readers.
We want to determine, what
is its true structure?
What is its true meaning?
The orphaning keeps teasing us,
to try to interpret what is
at the heart of this family?
I would like to emphasize again,
a seemingly unimportant
element of the play.
This chorus of orphans.
These orphans emphasize
the act of interpretation
because they witness the
supernatural destruction
of the monument to the Count of Narbonne.
They ask us to question
what does this mean?
What does this supernatural moment mean?
I'll just read a brief
excerpt from that scene.
The orphans are going in,
to see the Count of Narbonne's monument
and first orphan says,
"oh a storm so dreadful.
Some demon rides the air."
He continues describing the storm.
Martin says, "Twas well, but none of you,"
meaning the orphans,
"none of you had the courage
to face the fiend, to face the specter."
They continue a bit back and forth,
and the second orphan says, "I winked.
I saw the lightning
burst on the monument.
The shield of arms shivered to splinters.
ere I could repeat an Ave Maria.
Down came the hideous crash.
The cross came tumbling, and then I fled."
Martin says "retire.
This is unholy ground."
Last night we had that image of
I really liked that there was that image
of the broken monument
hovering over most of the play.
That's symbolic
representation of the father,
and his response to what's
happening in the family.
What is this broken monument?
Why is it broken?
I think it's important that the orphans,
this group of orphans are pointing
to that monument.
Thus orphaning emphasizes
a lack of knowledge about the family,
and it also emphasizes unequal knowledge
and unequal power,
in that act of interpretation.
Orphaning raises questions
that need to be answered,
but the answers are unclear.
Of course here we know,
it's only the Countess
that has the true answers.
Orphaning raises
confusion about parentage.
Confusion about place.
Confusion about the role in the family.
When Edmund is seeing his
mother for the first time,
we know, and I'll just list
a couple of key quotes.
The Countess responds,
and we saw this again, stage last night,
that Countess says ha is this sorcery,
or is it my husband?"
Edmund replies, "your parent, mother."
Correcting her, saying I am your son.
You are my mother.
The lack of knowledge about the family
leads to confusion, leads to displacement,
of the positions of the family.
Another example of Adeliza says,
"alas when I was then both a child of sin,
who were my parents?
I must pray for them."
But she does not know who her parents are,
and the Countess obviously
will not tell her.
A key moment of course,
is the horror of learning about parentage.
When that question of
orphaning gets answered,
it also answers the question with incest.
I'll just read a little
bit from that key scene,
when Edmund is confronting
his mother with his marriage,
and Edmund says, "Dear Parent, look on us,
and bless your children."
And the Countess replies, "my children.
Horror, horror.
Yes too sure.
Ye are my children."
That claiming that these are not orphans
but these are her children.
She's doing that with this full knowledge
that involves incest,
which of course at this moment,
Edmund doesn't understand
what that claiming means.
She continues, Edmund loose that hand.
It is poison to thy soul.
Hell has no venom like a child's touch.
Oh, agonizing thought.
Who made this marriage?
Whose unhollowed breath
pronounced the incestuous sounds?"
That's where we get that word incest,
but I think I want us to emphasize
that before we get to
the moment of incest,
we get to the claiming of the child.
We get to the question
of resolving orphaning.
We get this unique repetition
of the naming of familial position,
throughout this entire scene.
Let me read a little
bit more of the scene,
and again, emphasizing
that there has to be
this naming and renaming
of familial position,
because people, the characters,
are trying to interpret what is happening,
and there's this unequal knowledge,
where the Countess understands
the true familiar positions,
but the children do not.
The Countess continues, "lo'
where this mother stands.
Excuse me, where this monster stands.
Thy mother, mistress.
The mother of thy daughter.
Sister, wife.
The pillar of accumulated horrors."
She has to run through
all of these positions
within the family.
She's a monster because she's a mother,
mistress, daughter, sister, wife.
All of this collapsed together,
and trying to figure out
the correct structuring
of the family, and again, I would argue,
that it's not just incest,
but it's orphaning that has created
this familial confusion.
To conclude as I hope I've shown,
the orphan is central
to determining the logic
of Walpole's horror.
It's central to the
structuring of the play.
This is obviously a play
about familial horror,
about familial betrayal.
This horror comes from the ability
to redefine and restructure the family.
But I would argue it's a
restructuring that occurs
not just through incest,
but through orphaning.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
- Thank you Cheryl.
Our last speaker is Nicole Wright.
Nicole is an Assistant
Professor of English
at the University of Colorado, at Boulder.
She was recently a
Lapidis long term fellow
at the Shoenberg Center
at the New York Public Library.
Her articles have appeared
in "Eighteenth Century Fiction,"
Eighteenth Century Studies,"
"Eighteenth Century Theory
and Interpretation,"
"The Toronto Quarterly,"
and "The Chronicle of Higher Education."
She will speak today
to us on "'Kindest Laws':
Intimate Adjudication in
'The Mysterious Mother'."
- Thank you Jill for the introduction,
and thank you to Cindy,
Nicole, Michelle, and Sue,
for all they did to
prepare for this event,
and to The Lewis Walpole Library
for fostering some of my earliest
navigations of the archive
and its serendipities.
That term that Walpole popularized.
"What awful silence," Florian exclaims
at the beginning of "The Mysterious Mother."
With this sentence, the very first act,
the very first line of the first act,
Florian breaks the prevailing quiet.
Even as he directs attention to it.
The descriptor awful
compounds the suggestion
the holding intention
of opposing meanings.
Simultaneously, connoting
the awe and reverence
with which the faithful approach God,
and the dread evoked by the untold tale,
prior to the Countess's
ghastly revelation.
From the very beginning then,
Walpole's tragedy primes its audience
to balance dueling sensory
conditions and affective states.
Silence and cacophony, piety, and disgust.
Disgusting is one of
the terms that Walpole
notably uses when discussing
his play in correspondence.
The Janus-faced phrasing
of the first line
proceeds an abundance of similar locutions
throughout the play.
Such moments resonate as cues to the play's
audience of readers,
bringing to mind at
once original integrity,
and postlapsarian brokenness.
Essential honor and innate depravity.
As the play continues
it thus becomes clear,
that its dialogue reflects
a model for moral judgment.
Establishing its readers
as alternative arbiters,
who can evaluate the
Countess's crime of incest,
with more perspecuity than allowed
by the villain of the piece.
Friar Benedict, the predatory confessor.
The Countess is striving for atonement.
More specifically, her struggle
to take back or compensate for her crime,
has a formal analog I argue,
in the terminology of
simultaneous reiteration
and erasure that pervades the play.
As the Countess alternately hints at,
discloses, and renounces
her wrongful deed.
Certainly the Countess can
be reviled as a nymphomaniac
who abandons her duty to
mourn her venerable husband,
on the very night his bloody corpse
is delivered to her, no less,
and instead satisfies her urges
by deceiving her own
son into carnal embrace.
Yet, her unceasing efforts to serve
the most vulnerable
members of her community,
and repent for her crime,
are also foregrounded
via not only the plot,
but also the diction and
syntax of the play's dialogue.
The play's moral double vision
is also sustained through
the Countess's habit,
of palimpsest inscription,
in which she composes messages
that she subsequently
crosses out or weeps over
to the point that they
are almost illegible,
but can still be read in full
by those who come into
possession of her works.
As I will show, the Countess
and her children together
produce not only a transgression
that can be regretted
but never obliterated,
but also a model for how lay
people ought to deliberate
over even the most
apparently profound crimes,
and note that the Countess prefers to use
crime rather than sin.
A distinction that is
significant for my argument.
The model they demonstrate
abstains from judgment
from a distance.
From which characterological nuances
cannot be perceived,
and instead privileges
intimate adjudication
that takes into consideration,
Paimpsest moral complexity,
to make up an account to
use the phrase favored
by the Friars Martin and Benedict.
I argue that the problem
confronted by the play's audience,
how to judge the sensational
episode of double incest,
is eliminated by the template of judgment
that the Countess and Edmund generate
for assessing those in a
variety of circumstances.
Ranging from the poor souls
who flock to share in the
Countess's benevolence,
to the supposed infidels
who fall to Edmund's sword,
as they vie for power and sovereignty,
with Christians in far off lands.
Where else do we see
this model of judgment?
This moral priming emerging on the page.
One manifestation can be
found in the prefix un,
which is repeatedly associated
with the crime as she
terms it, of the Countess.
"Quick, unsay the monstrous tale,"
the Countess pleads upon hearing
that her children Adeliza and Edmund
have been united in matrimony by Benedict.
The profusion of un terms,
intoned by the Countess,
reflect her futile yearning
for her present words
to nullify her previous actions.
She asks Benedict whether he has come
to tutor my unapt nature.
Efface the stains.
Or is her attempt really in vain?
For evoking the impossibility
of returning to her previous condition,
of rectitude and dignity.
Her pleas seemingly ineffectual
in the world of the play,
can conjure for the audience
of readers a double vision.
Not only of her crime,
but also her prior integrity
and current virtue.
Thus cueing the audience to gauge
how practicable it would
be to unsay the tale.
Even if such a possibility,
is dismissed nearly as
soon as it is raised.
Referring to herself as the
unapt, unhinged, unnatural,
perpetrator of this secret
sin, this untold tale,
the Countess disassociates herself,
from several desirable
honorable qualities,
but the humiliated reason
with which she speaks
of what Benedict calls
her unheard of crimes.
Calls into question,
rather than reaffirms,
the notion that she
cannot find redemption.
After all other un reversals
are performed upon demand.
As one Edmund ordered
Benedict, "unriddle priest.
My soul is too impatient,
to wait the impertinence
of flowery dialect."
Or as when Florian later
commands the Friar,
"by my good sword, thou
shall unriddle priest."
The un injunctions are reminiscent
of similar contemplations of
morally freighted reversal
in Shakespeare whose literary influence
on The Mysterious Mother
has long been noted.
From Kent's reply in Leer,
"I cannot wish the fall undone,"
referring to the birth of his natural son.
Also named Edmund.
To Lady MacBeth's unsex me here,
and fill me to the crown
from the crown to the toe,
top-full. Of direst cruelty."
and here you can see how this connects up
with the rewriting of Macbeth
that Dale mentioned earlier.
In the Shakespearean context,
these wishes or demands
for moral reversals,
may be repented of, retroactively denied,
or incompletely fulfilled,
but in each case the speaker's
original morally blameless
state is brought to mind.
Even if only through an uttered negation.
Alongside their current moral condition.
To further complicate matters,
note that un is what linguists call
a bound morphing.
Bound because it does not
stand on its own as a word,
and morphing for its
power to radically morph,
change, reverse the word it modifies.
The prefix un though is ambiguous
in that while it sometimes
connotes the reversal of
some original condition,
it does not necessarily do so.
It can either negate
an excellent condition,
or indicate that a given condition
never existed in the first place.
While the guilt ridden Countess
frequently uses un words,
so does her blameless daughter Adeliza.
For the Countess, un means reversal
Adeliza un suggests an
original moral purity
that remains intact,
at least until she is wed
to her brother Edmund.
Prior to her unnatural union,
Adeliza is a maiden of
unblemished innocence.
She is unknowing and unfriended.
Linguistically linked
through terms of negation,
the guilty mother and
the innocent daughter
blur together as both are associated
with original moral goodness and dignity.
Even Benedict, who presents himself
as the play's moral aribiter,
fosters this bifurcated split
screen view of the countess.
During one of their frequent arguments,
he taunts her before announcing
the false news of Edmund's death.
"Learn if the mother's fortitude,
can brave the woman's arrogance."
Here Benedict divides the Countess
into the proud self serving woman,
and the long suffering sacrificial mother.
Elsewhere however, Benedict
defines the Countess
solely in terms of her crime.
His methodology of judgment
is presented as one that
the reader must reject.
He judges through gossip,
deduction, and insinuation.
Benedict steps in as an arbiter
to take advantage of the failure of law.
Law and "The Mysterious Mother"
is invoked primarily as
a disempowered neutered force.
That which Florian refers
to as nature's kindest laws,
a locution whose very tautology
evokes the play's double incest
has led the Countess and Edmund astray
as they follow their instinctive desires
to satisfy their sexual appetites.
Edmund prides himself on the fact
that he has not sapped my
countries laws, unquote,
but these laws likewise fail
to protect him from Perdition.
Benedict disavows any responsibility
to follow the laws of nation or king.
Of the church, he states,
"no laws I know but her prosperity.
No country, but her
boundless acquisitions."
Despite his apparent piety,
he is ruled not by
theological considerations,
but instead by his avarice.
It is indicative of the
Countess's reinstated
moral capacity that
she resists his efforts
to stand in judgment of
her as her confessor.
As Robert Miles notes,
the play advocates for
the sanctity of the individual conscience.
A self assertiveness
against the invasive power
of the patriarchal confession.
Rejecting the modes of
judgment offered by the law,
the play instead advocates
for intimate adjudication.
A practice relying on
proximity and familiarity.
In addition to the afore
mentioned capacity,
to remain mindful not only of
a person's current fallen state,
but also of their potential for goodness.
Sometimes this intimate adjudication
takes the form of embodied practice.
Adeliza judges the Countess best
when she knows her least.
Before she knows that she is her mother.
She can discern her moral capacity
through the gentleness with which
the Countess brushes
away a tear on a cheek.
For her part, the Countess admits
that before she regularly
and directly interacted
with the less fortunate of her community,
she misjudged them,
viewing them through
the lens of privilege,
akin to the just world hypothesis.
as it is now called.
She admits, "and if a pensive
visage crossed my path,
I deem the wearer envious or ill natured."
After her husband's death however,
she immerses herself in
the community of the poor,
and ceases to judge others so harshly.
Benedict acknowledges
that the healing touch
for which the Countess is known,
is beyond his own skill set.
When the Countess refuses to
divulge her secret to him in Act I,
he recommends that she
attend another holy man,
whose sanctity is marked by his gifts.
Miracles spring from his touch.
Yet for the Countess,
judging and redeeming those
who have made mistakes,
is not a matter of extreme measures.
Of lengthy pilgrimages and mere miracles.
Instead, it involves every
day embodied practice.
Listening to a tale, wiping away a tear.
The model of judgment
endorsed by the play,
encourages refraining from judging those
with whom one cannot encounter
in regular familiar proximity.
Recounting his participation
in battles with Turkish soldiers
over territory that would later
become to be known as Budapest,
Edmund asks, and this is a quote
from the quotation from the play.
"Befits it me,
Sprung from a race of heroes,
Narbonne's prince, to lend my
casual arm's approved valor.
quarrles, nor my countries nor my own.
To stain my sword of random blood!
I fought at Buda 'gainst the Turk--
I smote the turban'd race:
Did zeal, or did ambition nerve my blow!
or matter'd it to me, on Buda's domes?
Whether the crescent or
the cross prevailed."
Edmund asks whether he should have
abstained from intervening in quarrels
to which he is not a party.
Applied more broadly, he asks whether
one should judge those
whom one does not know.
Whose redeeming qualities are not known
and cannot be invoked to balance
against their supposed crimes.
His question recalls
the practice of judgment
endorsed in "Letter from Xo Ho,
A Chinese philosopher in London
to his friend Lien Chi at Peking."
Which Walpole published in 1757.
A year before he completed
"The Mysterious Mother."
In that letter, the Chinese philosopher.
Of the title disapproves
of the way in which
the English conduct trials,
but his apparent disapproval is tempered
by his explicit demurall from judgment.
Reason in China, he writes,
is not reason in England.
My friend Lien Chi,
I tell thee things as they are.
I pretend not to account for the conduct
of the Englishmen.
I told thee before they
are incomprehensible.
Peter Kitson has suggested
that the letter espouses,
quote, the view that China was or could be
the locus of moral authority.
As opposed to a corrupt Britain.
I see the letter as exemplifying
a universely available mode of judgment.
Giving Edmund's explicit aversion
to imposing his own judgment
on those he does not know,
the unusual history of Narbonne,
is an area that had a different point,
substantial Jewish and Muslim populations
may shed more light on
Walpole's mysterious tragedy.
Some earlier critics did
not devote much attention
to the significance of the area,
in which the play takes place.
In her 1974, critical edition
of "The Mysterious Mother,"
Janet Adele Dolan asserts,
setting in the mysterious mother
is relatively unimportant,
as far as plot is concerned.
Walpole chose to locate
his play in Narbonne,
a region in Southern France.
She leaves it at that.
Yet, Narbonne has a centuries old history
as the site of religious toleration,
and non judgment.
A place where non Christian persons
could at various points live in harmony
and practice their faith,
without legal restrictions or persecution.
Without being judged
for what they believed.
Narbonne is an important
site for Jewish and Muslim
as well as Christian history.
Reflecting a critical mass of
scholarship on the subject,
the scholar Benzion Netantyahu
contends that in the 700s Narbonne played
an unprecedented role,
in the history of European Jewry.
In The Mysterious Mother,
the Countess argues
that a person should be
judged by their good works,
not by their faith.
Countering Benedict's dictates.
Similar privileging of works
as a measure by which
character should be judged,
facilitated the thriving of
the Jewish community of Narbonne.
In the 700's they were
lauded by the kings,
for sharing their wealth.
For the public good.
Recognizing the services
rendered by the Jews
in relieving the economic
distress of his empire,
Charles overruled decrees,
and acted against the Jews
by Christian legislators
and granted the Jews of
Narbonne basic freedoms,
and the full protection of his government
exemption from judgment.
For the judgment of bigotry.
Judge by their works,
rather than by their faith.
The Jewish inhabitants of Narbonne
were able to live in harmony,
with Christians for several decades.
Indeed at some points,
non Christians ruled Narbonne,
for a four decade period in the 700's.
Islamic forces gained control of the area,
and used it as a base
for military campaigns.
Inside a Catholic church,
they built a Mosque.
Through its setting then,
the play reiterates Walpole's own call,
in his other writings,
for reason to replace bigotry,
in judging those of different faiths.
As one he defended the so
called Jew bill of 1753,
which would have expanded the rights
of Jewish people living in England,
but was repealed due
to nativist sentiment.
There are other examples of authors,
writing, reiterating,
the debate over the Jew
bill in the early 1760's.
To be qualified to
judge others adequately,
"The Mysterious Mother" suggests,
one would do well to practice
intimate adjudication.
To define a person, not
only by a singular crime,
but also by the balance
of their character.
To interact frequently
and directly with others,
whom one judges,
and to refrain from judging those
in communities with whom one does
not enjoy close acquaintance.
Perhaps the kindest law,
for would be judges to keep
in mind, the play suggests,
is to remain cognizant of the extent
to which they remain un or
at least not yet cognizant.
Thank you.
(audience applause)
- Who would like to get
our discussion started?
Tasha, there's a mic behind you.
Thank you.
- [Tasha] Hello, can you hear me?
Well thanks so much to all of you
for your papers which were
really stimulating and thought provoking.
Just because it's on my mind,
I have a question about the last paper.
I was wondering.
I guess I was just wondering,
if you could reflect a little bit
on the relationship between adjudication
and the mystery structure,
which may also sort of
be a point of contact
with some of the other papers.
I was thinking about, how the prefix, un,
has both the two qualities
that you pointed out,
so that it can cancel something out
that's already happened.
Retroactive negation.
It can be, what was the second one?
A sort of state of
purity or non existence,
and it seems that the third
that might be relevant
for the mystery plot
is that it can be an anticipatory un.
So unheard can be something
that isn't yet spoken,
and I guess I was just wondering,
it was very interesting to me
to think about the play as staging
a scene of judgment,
or an alternative confession in some way.
As opposed to the
epistemological question,
that is at the heart of the mystery.
This sort of, how did the
maybe more prurient interest
in what is true,
how does that intersect,
with the moral questions
that you're asking
us to pay attention to?
- Thank you,
and I do think that
connotation is certainly.
That third connotation
certainly is there as well.
One thing I noticed is
especially in the roughly
the first half of the play or so,
is you see this prefix un,
invoked by the Countess in
ways that tantalizes others.
Whether consciously or unconsciously.
To know more about her tale.
To draw it out of her,
and I'm also thinking about
how that connects up,
with the composition history,
of The Mysterious Mother
too, that Dale mentioned,
this alternating disclosure,
and retrenchment in which
Walpole himself engages.
It's this notion that we're anticipating
this disclosure that hasn't yet arrived.
- Misty.
- [Misty] Thanks everyone
for those papers.
I have a question for Matthew,
but it might fan out.
I think you've done a beautiful job,
showing us us that queer
space, of gothic obsession
in Walpole, and that kind of bifurcation
which we talked about a little yesterday,
between the aesthetic of Catholicism.
An aesthetics that is Catholic,
and a theology that's Catholic.
I'm wondering if, and I realize
you're coming at this as an art historian,
but is there a kind of
queer theology that
this crypto Catholicism is articulating
that's more than just this
same sex erotic space.
If there's a sort of properly
theological queerness.
- I think that there definitely is,
whether Walpole understood
it to be as such,
I'm less certain.
There is of course a
growing debate about this,
in terms of scholarship on camp and performance,
and the extent to which
these things offer.
Rather than seeing camp as something,
that's something kind of facile, and
simply just performative
in sync with performance.
Actually camp offers a
really vital and serious way
of actually engaging with these issues
outside of any other kind of performative mode.
I think that may be a really interesting
way to start into this.
Because things like these
masses they actually do are,
at least in terms of Walpole's circle
quite odd and quite strange,
and I can't think of
many others that are done
with at least a certain
degree of reverence,
because in that particular letter,
Walpole says that they had some masses.
They pulled down some mass books.
They had a really good time with incense
and then they went and played cards.
There is a kind of in the letter,
it does actually lead you from something
which is quite sacred,
to something which is quite literally fun.
But actually I don't think
that actually diminishes
the first part of that,
which is important to me,
so in my work I try to come back
with a little bit more gravity.
If that answers your question.
- Just to get back to that,
I think a lot of the work
of 18th century gothic
is actively to queer Catholicism.
Both as a kind of institution
or a historical practice,
but also as a theology.
What happens, in something
like Lewis's "The Monk."
The figure of Mary is queer.
And there's an erotic relationship
Ambrosia has with the figure of Mary,
and that's to exclude
all of those fantasies
about same sex queer desiring
in spaces like convents and monasteries.
Love in a convent.
Things like that.
But I think Protestant
writers of gothic
are certainly involved in the
queering of Catholicism.
- I think David has
a question and the mic.
So we'll go next to David.
- [David] This is for Cheryl.
Orphaning is a deliberate
act of power really,
so I'm just trying to think,
whether you have any other examples,
or I'm just trying to run through
all my 18th century plays I know,
that certainly do often,
the way that you described it
is very very powerful.
Are there any other novels
or plays that you've found,
where the mother of the parent
is in control?
- Usually it's the opposite,
where there's that
mystery that no one knows
and it gets revealed at the end,
and I'm trying to think of
one that involves a mother
that is actively orphaning a child,
and I'm not coming up with
one off the top of my head.
I don't know if anybody
else can think of any,
but I'll keep pondering it.
I think that the structure though,
of this figure that is clearly,
has a mystery about their parentage.
We know that's at the heart
of so many 18th century texts,
and that does wind up
really working its way
into the gothic,
and winds up being a
key way of structuring
multiple mysteries,
and I would say concentrated then
in the orphan itself,
and I'm just trying to think of,
lots of the novels of
Charlotte Smith for example,
focus on an orphan figure,
that ultimately has to be reclaimed.
I guess all of the novels of Burbey.
We could probably start
naming lots of them.
That sense of a rejected
child, being reclaimed,
but usually it revolves
around the father figure,
and not such a purposeful orphaning.
Yeah, later Bleak House.
I think Bleak House gives us
that sort of post 18th century clarity
of how important orphaning is
to the structuring of the family.
Again, bringing in all the
legal aspects of orphaning.
But I think that's why,
I would say that's why
maybe this play, I would,
I think we can probably
continue to think of examples
but I say that was one of the things that
makes this play horrific in a way,
is that it is because of a mother
purposely choosing to orphan a child.
If we think of incest as one pole
of a horrific act a
parent should never do,
I think the willful
disclaiming of a child,
and positioning a child as an orphan
is another sort of horrific act.
- Yeah, and I'm just going pick up,
and connect that to something
Nicole talked about, Nicole Garret.
I was so interested Cheryl,
that you describe the father's death.
Even if the mother surviving legally,
most cases that would
make a child an orphan,
but as you say, the Countess in a way
is acting like a father,
in her act of orphaning her own child.
It's so much more common in Evelina.
Evelina has been in effect
disclaimed, by her father.
So I'm interested in the idea of the Countess
as a mysterious father,
but there's some way in which
she is part of her crime as,
being more like a father than mother,
or in those crazy relations,
where the incest doubles,
mother mistress mother of
your sister daughter wife,
that already the Countess has somehow
put herself in a position
of the dead father,
and I just wondered if any of you Cheryl
or Nicole or others, want to?
- I think it's not very
uncommon in fictions
that feature single mothers
for them to take on part of that role,
or to resist that role
and also for it to be
regardless of the familial situation
or the money situation,
to be seen as unnatural and masculine.
We see that with "Roxana."
It's in "Sidney Bidulph."
I don't know if in "The Natural Daughter"
you could call that willful orphaning,
but it was one of the
ones that came to mind,
but there's usually little
choice in the matter.
This is going back into the
last question a little bit.
Thinking about the fatherhood,
what is intriguing to me,
is at what point does she become a father,
and whether we can connect that,
to the original incest act.
Does she become a
tyrannical gothic father,
along the lines of the Count of Narbonne,
in the Jephson play later,
at the moment their husband dies?
Is that why she's capable of that act?
Is it this situation where she moves from
the maternal and the female,
into the paternal and
gothic sort of fatherhood.
I'm not really sure,
but in terms of behaving like a father
that is just something that comes up
in single mother fictions
of the period a lot,
and that they really
do try to wrestle with
in a number of different ways.
- I think I would build on that and say
probably she steps into that role
of the tyrannical father
when she banishes Edmund.
That sort of decision to remove him,
which again I would say
is an orphaning-like act,
but that seems to be where she really
positions herself as powerful.
But I think that the play
is very interested in
thinking through economic
motherhood, fatherhood,
and the gendering of that,
but also the emotions.
I think that's where,
it's a lot of fun the way
it was put up on the stage last night,
to sort of highlight this idea
of the emotions of the mother.
At some points she can be imperious,
and take on a certain masculinity,
but at other points she seems to be
very feminine, fainting and shocked.
- If we think of the play
as containing vestiges of Lear,
which I see everywhere in the play.
There's also echoes of the
rejection of Cordelia.
- But I think like the genre
or the mode that he inaugurates,
Walpole's work is thoroughly preoccupied
with what we might call
the paternal function.
Rather than actual biological paternity,
he has an interest what much later
psychoanalysts would call
the paternal metaphor,
or the range of functions
usually wielded by a father
who is not necessarily
the biological father,
and I think what Walpole, what happens
in both Otranto and elsewhere in Walpole,
is that he's interested in
drawing a very firm distinction
between an outdated version
of the paternal function--
a tyrannous perverse father,
like Manfred in "Otranto,"
with whom he juxtaposes in Otranto,
a range of enlightened fathers,
who are much more sentimentally engaged,
and who weep when they're
reconciled to their children.
There's a very firm distinction,
between types of fathers in "Otranto,"
but I think that follows through
to "The Mysterious Mother,"
where you have an outdated
version of the paternal function.
The kind of tyrannous father.
The father of perverse enjoyments
that Freud will talk about
in "Totem and Taboo."
In the form of fathers or
friars, Benedict and Martin,
as I see it with the Catholic past.
Nonetheless he removed
the paternal function
from the Count,
and preempting psychoanalytic
accounts of desire
and law and paternity, incest erupts,
when you've moved the paternal function,
so she has to kind of step into
the role of a reformed father.
Reformed in all senses of that word,
in order to keep the paternal function,
and with that, the law,
the circulation of desire, etc. operating.
I think Walpole is deeply interested
in the paternal function,
and drawing distinctions between
very blandly put, good and bad fathers.
- She gets to be both types, of father
the reformed and the outdated.
And isn't that Walpole
constructed in his own life,
in multiple fathers.
Horace Mann, who is one of these.
There's many many others,
and in my own work I explore
both family romance and
queer family romance.
This possibility of adopting
an alternate non biological family.
Could someone say something
about Walpole as an orphan?
Not just his contested parentage,
but the idea of being an orphan,
also as a kind of
interesting queer metaphor
in and of itself potentially,
but could someone speak to that?
- Would you just say a
little bit more about,
just go down the path you were going,
that it's a queer metaphor.
Explain that a little bit more.
What you're thinking.
That's great.
- In particular cultures, the orphan,
queer child being essentially the orphan,
often without family
or distance from family
for that reason,
and Walpole's own contested parentage
of course makes him something
potentially of an orphan.
Distance from his own father too.
His rather emotional
relationship with his own mother
which is also somewhat contested.
- I would take a stab at that by saying,
that I think the orphan allows there to be
the act of construction of the family.
Rather than relying on biological bonds.
It's sort of erasing that
as the main structure of the family.
It opens up all these possibilities
for what is the structure of
the family going to be then?
If it's not biological bonds,
it can be what you want it to be.
So it opens up that possibility
for queering I think.
That's just a quick response,
but I think that's what again,
is sort of being played around with,
with "The Mysterious Mother,"
if you're actively erasing family bonds,
that are biological,
then what do you put in its place?
I think that could be something
that's seen as strategic,
in a way that you're getting at
that is empowering,
and I think with "The Mysterious Mother,"
we see the downside or
the alternative of that,
where it becomes a ultimately,
it's a source of power,
but ultimately, it's gonna
turn back in on itself,
and become the very source of downfall.
I guess I'd want to think
about it a bit more.
I think that what I would say is that
without biological bonds,
you're therefore able to create bonds
that are very text based,
or like you were emphasizing ritual based.
It opens up all these other forms
of constructing relationships,
and putting the power in
those forms of construction.
- I must admit,
I hadn't thought of it
until I heard your paper.
Thank you very much.
- Well I'm just thinking of it now.
- Bouncing off that,
I'm also thinking about,
as you say creating textual bonds.
Walpole's work on the writing of history
and historiography connected with
the idea of the queer
entity and no future.
The writing of history as a substitute
for biological progeny in a way.
- But I think this comes across strongly
in "The Mysterious Mother" in particular.
If we're going to think about the orphan
as a queer figure,
what is crucial is that
the orphan's desire
is not oedipalized, and
cannot be oedipalized.
It's deterritorialized, in
deleuzian and guattarian sense,
but what is interesting
is the threat that poses
to any kind of symbolic system,
because look at how Adaliza
is continuously coerced into the convent
or into her marriage.
Her desire has to be managed,
and oedipalized in a sense,
because she even though
she's not really an orphan
but she believes herself to be an orphan.
Her way of desiring exceeds
oedipal triangles
and safely controllable modes of desiring.
- At the same time,
one thing that's strange
to me about the play
is how often Adeliza's
consent is explicitly sought.
It's of course disavowed or ignored later,
but there's this explicit request.
Do you consent?
At least twice in the play.
- I think we have a couple more questions,
and just a tiny bit more time,
so let's get into.
- [Georgina] Quite a lot of
what I was going to ask
has already been covered,
with the very lovely
discussion about orphaning,
but I was going to say
something about incest.
Actually unsay what I said yesterday
about incest being the
worst thing after murder.
In fact, the thing that incest
really harms is the child.
You could get away with having incest
if both people were infertile.
You're not gonna have children.
I also think that in that particular
familial environment, if
we're gonna call it that.
There is no respect for
maternal or paternal love.
What's prioritized all
the time is sexual desire,
and what we could call love or passion,
and I do think that she is
a very masculine character.
One of the things she wants,
masculine but also feminine.
She has to behave like a man,
because she wants the state.
She wants to keep control of the state,
which is nobody's really covered the fact,
that women and territory
is very important,
and in a way I think that's the way
that she can hold on to
who she's pretending to be
as long as she's got that,
this is mine.
The other thing I'd like to say,
is that actually Edmund doesn't seem to
give a toss about his dad either.
I mean, nobody's really looked
at what it's doing to him,
to live in that environment.
He ends up being a sort of orphan as well,
but he's got a narrative as well,
and I think her journey if you want
is about discovering
a degree of femininity
in the way people understand femininity
as beneath men,
and one of the things that she
can defend herself from that
is by keeping control of the state.
She says the state is mine,
and I will let you know what to do with.
Thank you very much.
I think that that's a very important,
especially at that time.
I don't know what Walpole
thought about that,
but he's certainly looking at it.
- I think the thing about incest
that I find intriguing,
takes me back to Jill's
wonderful article on the play,
is how heterosexual incest,
in the late 18th century,
is also a cipher for a
much more unspeakable
form of desire which
is homo erotic desire.
It's the most visible of the so-called
sexual perversions
which have yet to be named
and constituted as such,
but occupy the same amorphous category
called sodomy in the period
and heterosexual incest is often used
as a cipher for same sex desiring.
Certainly in Walpole,
but also in Beckford,
and in Lewis.
That's what Jill's written on.
- Walpole often links his love
for his male correspondents
and his general coterie of male friends,
to just by proximity in his letters
to these often comic
and grotesque anecdotes
about heterosexual incest.
Joe has a question, or a thought.
- [Joe] Thank you.
Yes, it's thrilling to hear
these papers individually
and in an ensemble of creating
a whole context of world,
in Walpole's mind, in the theater,
and its various contributory features,
but before we break,
I wonder if anyone has a
kind word for Sophocles.
(audience laughing)
Exile, return, discovering.
The mother gets it.
Right on the case.
Early on.
Maybe even before the
Corinthian messenger arrives.
- The difference is of
course the level of intent
and consciousness with which
the mother certainly commits
the first act of incest.
Where there is no unconscious inoperation.
Although Electra and Phaedrus,
and other plays in
the classical tradition,
certainly work their way into
the construction of incest in the play.
I think Walpole's a bit nervous
or a bit anxious to engage too closely
with the classical tradition here,
because of the broader
political imperatives,
of resisting French
Neo-classicism in the play.
He instead would look, as
we discussed last night,
to other models of tragedy.
Without necessarily reiterating,
or following closely,
a classical tragic formulas,
but there certainly are records there,
and this I suppose amplified
by the fact that,
once Walpole has written the play,
several of his friends and correspondents
write him saying, oh I found
a version of the story in this text.
I found a version of story in that text.
and several people are
almost without undermining
his claims to original genius.
Did you know that this happens here?
He claims with a lot of them,
not to have known about them,
but that's only kind of provides grist
to his own mill that he has
successfully articulated
something archetypal,
and something that is in a
kind of cultural unconscious
and always has been,
and perhaps always will be,
and in that way, the play itself,
aspires to a mythological
status of its own,
in the way that "Oedipus" has.
- Maybe you can even think of it,
as Walpole orphaning himself.
Severing himself from this classical
literary genealogy,
because remember he writes
back and forth to Mason,
who keeps encouraging him to
revise the Countess character
so that she's deceived.
So she doesn't know that she's
encountering her own son.
There seems to be some
kind of disassociation,
of that literary lineage.
- I would say just our
familiarity with Sophocles,
and I think all of us
know that we're reading
an incest plot as soon
as we pick up the play,
but when I was watching last night,
it was making me think I was
trying to imagine an original reader,
which in some ways is the
theme of this session,
and trying to imagine if
they would not have known,
the answer to the mystery was incest.
If they were figuring it out,
much earlier in the play,
or knew it before they
even picked up the play,
or if they would have been
shocked at that moment of horror,
when all is revealed towards the end.
I was trying to think
through some of the papers
as they were being given.
How much the readership would have known
the scandalous nature of the story.
Before they've even picked
up the play is probably true,
but I was trying to figure out,
the original reader
slash viewer of the play.
Would they have known the mystery or not?
- I think we have time just
for this last question.
- [Man] Thank you so much.
I have a question that
is specifically for Dale,
because your paper got me thinking
about the epigraph on the title page
of the 1768 from Virgil,
which seems to just completely embody
the ambivalence of
revealing and concealing.
I translated it.
May it be lawful for me to
speak all that I have heard,
and this is when the Sybil
is speaking in book six,
and I also think it's interesting too
because the Latin, this word fas,
is actually indeclinable,
so it has a type of
imbalance, in and of itself,
and I was just wondering,
if you considered that at all,
when you're thinking
about your paper, firstly,
and secondly, what happens
to that epigraph over time,
because I think I saw it disappear,
after the 1768 printing.
- Can you read me the translation again?
What is it?
- [Man] This is my translation.
May it be lawful for me to speak
all that I have heard?
- Okay.
- [Man] And that word fas is,
it means divine law,
or law or rule,
and it's indeclinable,
so it's sitting on the line.
- Okay.
What is interesting is,
I haven't thought about the
epigraph in that context
but what is interesting,
is it brings to mind his mangling
of classical sources as epigraph,
in "Otranto" and he shifts an epigraph,
and misquotes it from a Latin source,
but the other thing that strikes me
is that that seems to
be a classicist version
of the same sentiments
that would be expressed
by the ghost of Hamlet's father,
in Hamlet, I could a tale unfold,
in the kind of I could a tale unfold.
That would harrow out their soul,
and freeze thy blood and all the rest,
which becomes the kind of mantra
of gothic writing after Walpole.
So that sense of the ineffable.
Read it again.
The translation.
- [Man] May it be lawful for me to speak
all that I have heard, and the Latin is
sit mihi fas audita loqui
- Yeah, the ineffable.
Things that come to mind are
notions of the ineffable,
about the kind of subjunctive mood
that we get in I could
a tale unfold in Hamlet.
A kind of reserve of horror
that is not quite articulable descriptive.
That which lies beyond
the powers of language,
and indeed representation
and I think there is a concern
in The Mysterious Mother,
of the unrepresentable,
and that which can only
be circled by language.
There's a lot of stuff
that happens off stage
that we don't see,
and a lot of stuff that
can't be represented.
Which later becomes this concern
with the ineffable in gothic writing.
That's kind of how I would approach that,
although I haven't thought
about the epigraph.
- Perspectively it also looks
toward a period of greater freedom
in a certain sense doesn't it,
that I will be able to do these things.
It actually really arguably,
is actually a kind of Latin paraphrase,
or another version of fari quar sentiat
say what one feels,
which of course is Walpole's own motto.
So potentially it is actually
another version of that basic idea
about liberty in a sense.
- I cut a little bit out of the prologue
that I recited at the beginning
of the performance yesterday,
which was actually about how
ridiculing the French,
who were so rule bound,
for having anything really significant
or horrific take place off stage,
and here in England we
don't have to do that.
It doesn't have to be
reported by a gazette.
You're going to see it,
but easier to just ascribe
this problem to the French
than actually in fact, Walpole,
this whole wonderful set of papers,
makes me think he doesn't want
to simply put it before us.
He wants to create a space,
where as you each brought
out in different ways,
is said and not said,
or unsaid, or taken back.
Where things are moving
in and out of the space
and some kind of graspability
knowing part is the bed trick
that a countess knew more than others knew
and that's part of the
act of transgression.
Thank you all so much for coming today
to help us continue to contemplate
this remarkable and mysterious
and very rich work,
and please join me in thanking
all of our speakers for this
wonderfully rich and suggestive ensemble
as Joe put it, of papers.
(audience applause)